- On espère rester là pour
longte
cette loi, ça risque de mettre
en cause notre immigration.
- Les projets d'achat
d'une maison viennent
Carbonara et sa famille,
arrivés il y a moins d'un an.
Ils ont quitté leur maison
en France avec le désir
de s'é C C C C C C C C C C C C ,
travailleuse temporaire
esesest pas du donnant-donnant,
c'est on nous accepte pour
la main-d'oeuvre, mais
d'accéder à la propriété.
- La d d devra patienter,
car avec le moratoire imposé
par Ottawa, seuls les citoyens
permanents peuvent acheter
b b bien immobilier résidentie.
Quelques exceptions sont
tout de même prévues à la loatat
d'immeubles résidentiels
par des non-Canadiens.
Les résidents temporaires,
les réfugiés ou les membanananat
devenir propriétaires.
Laurie Carbonara et son conjoint
pourraient donc réaliser
leur rêve à Lonmemememememememer
travaillé trois ans au Canada.
- Puis c'est frustrant
parce qu'on avait vraiment
l'espoir d c c c c c c c c c c e
c'est une loi qui vise à limiter
la spéculation. La spéculation,
elle ne vient pas des famillesrr
leur résidence principale.
- Selon la Société d'hypothèque
et de logement, les étrangers  %
des propriétaires résidentiels
des grandes régions
métropolitaines du pays.
très prisés et certains endroits
sont plus populaires que
d'autres pou
de logement. À l'Île-des-Soeurs,
les non-Canadiens sont
propriétaires de 7,8 %
de Toronto, 4,1 % des condos
appartiennen é é é é étrangers.
Et ils seraient 2,7 %
dans la péninsule Burrard,ereree
est venue ralentir le phénomè
CHARLES-OLIVIER AMÉDÉE-MANESME,
professeur titulaire, U de Laval
d'achat des étrangers.
C'est vraiment un achat qui est
dû aux Canadiens. Donc, en fait,
forcément régler ce problème,
elle vient empêcher que
les étrangers amènent
le problème.
NATALIE BELOVIC,
agente immobilière
- On a vu dans la région
d'Ottawa des gens
qui déménageaient pendant
la pandémie de Toronto,
qui payaient des prix fous,
des standards d'Ottawa,
parce que pour eux, déjà,
en venant de Toronto,
c'était tellement moins cher.
- Laurie Carbonara pense
qu'elle n'aurait pas entamé
un processus d'immigration
si cette loi avait été
en vigueur lors
de ses démarches.
Elle a tout de même espoir
que des changements seront
apportés à la loi pour aider
les travailleurs immigrantes
comme elle.
Ici Carla Oliveir